hey youtubers is Charlie so new Game of
Thrones Season 7 Casas announced I have
a couple ideas about who it might be so
just careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened so far so based on some
of the casting descriptions that the
Watchers people found out a couple weeks
ago there are three really solid picks
of who he could be playing now I do
think that he's playing someone inside
the Citadel just because he's a very
bookish person he tends to play
characters like that like think
Professor Slughorn from Harry Potter
like where would that you know that type
of character actor fit into the Game of
Thrones world now they don't always play
the same types of characters but it's
not like he's a warrior and one of the
people in the casting descriptions is
meant to be a general then there's a
priest and then there's a merchant now
the merchant sounds like it's a one-off
person that runs into Daenerys as people
as she's sailing around but the priest
might just be a mask for a maester that
they're trying to cast inside the
Citadel because if you didn't know what
a maester was he didn't know what that
term meant and you just saw someone like
that walking around in robes you would
think that they're a priest so that
might be a ruse to cast someone inside
the Citadel for Samwell storyline now
maester Marwin is a really important
character given what they need to do on
the show like the things that Samwell
needs to learn about in the characters
that they have not cast yet but they did
say that whoever jim broadbent is
playing it's a very very significant
role so even though he's not meant to
appear in every single episode it's
still a very important role in the
context of the show which is why I think
maester Marwan is a really solid pick so
if you don't know who Marwan is he's one
of the few people inside the Citadel
he's an arch maester he's not just a
maester he's an arch maester so he sits
on what you would think of as the ruling
council of the Citadel but the problem
is is his area of study is the occult
Dragons all the really cool stuff magic
in the other maesters really do not like
that he's called Marwan the mage and
they call him that is a slight they try
to ostracize him he spends most of his
time hanging out closer to the harbor
and eventually in the books runs into
Samwell where Samwell explains what's
going on and then Marwan decides I'm
gonna go help Daenerys he wants to go
become Daenerys as maester in the books
now remember the TV show has diverged
dramatically from what's happening in
the books but the thing is is that
Marwan
in his time as a Meister traveled the
world learned all about warlock shadow
binders dragons he went to the Far East
where Melisandre is from he's been all
over the world including the place where
Daenerys dragon eggs came from so he's
just this incredible source of
information for stuff that we need to
learn on the show we need to learn how
to fight White Walkers
we need more context for the war for the
dawn even though bran is learning a lot
about this because he's the new
three-eyed Raven Samwell is the other
side of the equation he might learn how
to forge Valyrian steel he might be the
one to have the idea to use dragon stone
and all the dragon glass there to arm
against the White Walkers so there's
just a bunch of really complex really
cool information that the show needs to
convey in this new jim broadbent
character is a good opportunity for that
to happen inside the Citadel like Oh
Samwell you want to learn about this
well these are all these books over here
this is where you need to be looking or
even if he's not Marwan he could just be
a foil for Sam wells character inside
the Citadel that helps Samwell come to
conclusions in a roundabout way and we
don't really know how much Samwell we're
gonna get
there's only gonna be about seven
episodes so I would expect like an equal
amount of Samwell that we got in season
six which means very little but it's
still very important in the funny thing
like usually this doesn't matter but I
will say Jim Broadbent does physically
resemble maester marwan's description in
the books he has this thick neck strong
jaw he's really short squat he's almost
like an older version of Samwell that's
not quite so heavy so does that not look
like Jim Broadbent like he could totally
pull that off the old professor inside
the Citadel that helps Samwell learn all
the cool things that he needs to know
about the occult to help them fight the
white walkers but let me know in the
comments who do you think the Jim
Broadbent is playing if you know the
types of roles that he typically gets
cast in think about the different
storylines that we're going to have we
have the battle for King's Landing so we
have like Daenerys Cersei stuff that's
going on we have Jon Snow up in the
north then we have Samwell at the
Citadel so just looking over the casting
descriptions like all the people that he
could possibly be each of the characters
calls for a highborn British accent so
that means he's a noble or he's very
learned he's not going to be like a
peasant that you would bump into in flea
bottom so that's why I think it's a
pretty safe bet that he's going to show
up inside
Citadel and he'll be the tv-shows
version of maester Marwin now remember
the TV show is very different from the
books so even if he doesn't have
marwan's name I think he'll be doing
some of the things that Marwan does in
the books so it'll be a rampant Easter
eggs for the Citadel in the books but
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner doom box you win a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details there is a new
round that starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video they did just
start shooting season 7 now so I would
expect more casting announcements like
this to roll out throughout the rest of
the year so hopefully we'll find out
about some of the other really big
characters there are a couple other big
ones but right now they're not sounding
like too many book characters so just
remains to be seen but what's gonna
happen next is I'm working on a Justice
League Deathstroke video the rumor is is
that Joe Manganiello is going to be
playing him in the movie but there are a
couple other big actors that I think
could pull it off so that video will
post next what are you wait for that to
post you can click here to learn how
Cersei is doing exactly the same things
that an ancient Targaryen King used to
do and you can click here for the season
7 teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you